the problem with school and
and sort of back to everything that this
article um
summarizes is that we all go to school
we all take the same useless classes
algebra biology chemistry trigonometry
wood shop even
but they don't teach you money classes
like they don't teach you again here
how to balance a budget how to you know
deal with debt credit cards
92 they don't teach you these skills
they teach you how to work
they teach you how to get a job but they
don't teach you what to do with the
money when you get the damn job
and that's the problem that's
essentially what this article is there's
a financial
illiteracy crisis in this country
absolutely but tell us about yours what
was yours like what was yours
when did your parents cut you off or did
they so
my first job out of first of all i had
my first job when i was 15 which adam
knows it
i lied on my on my job application my
first technical job i said
i said i was 16 even though it was just
queen little caesars right here
and by the way no no car i had no car um
but
when i got out of business school it was
the first and last time i ever had debt
ever i had my student loans from getting
my mba
so i go off to wall street i turned i
turned down a job with arthur anderson
to become an accountant
and it was for more money and it was
they were gonna put put me up in
corporate housing they were gonna pay
for my last nine hours to sit for my cpa
and i'm like you know what i'm just not
a bean counter
i'm going off to wall street i'm gonna
go in sales so
uh i get the i'm making so little money
that it covers my student loan payment
and my rent
and that's it so my mom is sending me a
hundred dollars a month to get my dry
cleaning out of hoc
so and but the minute i mean when i when
i
was probably nine months in what does
that sound by the way
you hear that sound no okay probably
when i'm nine months in
nine whatever i i paid off my student
loans i got
i got a huge commitment quickly
commission check and i well i was a rock
star
on wall street um so i mean i but i
wasn't captain of the football team
so well you could have been i feel like
you could be captain of whatever you
want to do with life
captain of your own show so she pays off
her debt nine months in and she's
kicking ass on wall street so the minute
my mom turned 50
i paid it forward i flew her up to new
york
took her to a day at vidal sassoon we
had a blast
it was totally how old were you at that
time when that happened
27. how sick is that by the way let me
ask you
yeah and then i bought her a ranch
outside of a m
you bought no joke you like ranch
dressing
iola texas google that it's it's you
can't even find it on a map
so i know i know i didn't buy ranch just
so you know when you were in
high school and you were before the
military i know that you had a you know
a 3.8 gpa
you were 40 000 in debt your dad paid it
off you were a privileged child
extremely tell us tell us your story no
you know you have to realize i don't
even know what allowance is like you
know when people talk about allowance i
don't
know what a lot my mom's never given me
allowance like i'm telling you
never when i tell you never i'm not
kidding with you i've never gotten an
allowance i've had to
make my own money when we went to
germany i learned how to make my own
money at 10 years old from that moment
on i was going to find a way to get my
hands on money
minus selling drugs never sold drugs
never sold anything uh illegal although
i come from a lineage of bootleg
of prohibition what do you call it
though
my uncle was one of them one of the best
he was one of the best
he was the best she was one of the best
he was the greatest bootlegger we've
ever seen
jfk's father was a bootlegger that's
right the kennedy family establishment
yes yes
so i uh i found a way to make money and
uh
in the first car i got was a 1979 honda
accord
same as you except five years honda
accord that would only go drive
it wouldn't go reverse so we would have
to park my buddies
that would probably that's the one
that's the one right there yellow no no
right there no no go right there you you
had it
go back 79 you had it go right there top
left that's the one
that's the one i had yellow just like
that that was mine you're killing it
yeah i mean it was that's exactly the
car i had
and it got to a point where it wouldn't
drive past 35 miles and my dad and i had
to go drop it off to uh uh
we sold it for 500 bucks we're driving
out to a place to sell it i went from
glendale
all the way to upland on 118 and 210
freeway going 35 miles an hour and the
furthest line to the right just
visualize that
i'm like just don't see me you know your
flasher's on yeah
so but but the point is say that again
like adam driving the go-kart
it's like adam driving a go-kart that's
that's a good great visual
have you ever gotten a ticket for going
too slow i know you get tickets for
going too
fast yeah my honda accord could only
drive for a certain period of time
you know how you put the car in drive
yeah uh and
and you don't if you like i would step
on the gas pedal the car would shut off
so i drove home 30 miles why is it so
easy i know that story i actually yeah
it was just i believe in you so the
point is here's the point
i i i don't know the concept of
supporting at the levels of people being
supported today
right but also let me fly and they're
destroying their kids i also don't know
what it is
to be raised by parents who have access
to the resources that others don't like
i don't know what it is to be
so say your last name is obama say your
last name is trump say your last name is
kennedy say your last name is vanderbilt
say your last name is gates or any of
that i don't know what it is to have
that last name either so
for to to be fair for both sides i don't
what do you do if you're a billion
dollars what do you do with the kids
there there's also that challenge
what do you do with your kids i mean
you're well off i mean you're gonna send
your kids to nice schools you're gonna
you know how are you gonna what do you
do with your kids
there's an answer for this because okay
i've got a 17 year old and a 15 year old
who are at boarding school
so you put money on their debit card
and it's a once a month thing and when
they run out of the money
and they call you for extra before the
first of the month you say
i love you but i am sorry all right but
you're putting money on their cards
you're giving them
money or an allowance to what age to
what age you're going to do then
you know probably through college
probably through college you'll do that
how much do they get a month if you
don't mind
uh they they get a hundred and fifty
dollars a month
just so you guys know you don't have
here you're not hearing anything now
okay come come come
can you come listen to this come listen
to this come listen to this i wanna
speak i can hear you guys continue just
listen to what my i hear like there's
like three birds chirping in the
background
if it's just mine i'll work with it but
go ahead so you have a debit you have a
debit card
you need a padded room here so you have
a you've got terrorism because you guys
don't hear anything i'm good it's a
conspiracy theory
you give it to them the moment it runs
out they get nothing so the 17 year old
the 17 year old goes through it like
water first few weeks
i mean consistently he's starting to
learn the 15 year old
i mean this this kid is frugal and the
rule
is anything that's left over at the end
of the month gets swept into a savings
account
i love that system you know what other
system i think about i would do i i
would probably
so it's still making that noise okay so
here i'm not going cuckoo here the
sounds of birds alex
is eye tweeting so so what i would do
what i would i'm gonna put it on and
i'll just
act as if there's two birds right behind
me so what i would
what i would do is i would do a system
of matching
meaning at a certain age i'm gonna do a
match per
dollar you make i'll give you four
dollars and gradually it'll go down
so if you make five hundred dollars a
month guess what i'll give you
fifteen hundred dollars if you make uh a
thousand dollars a month i'm gonna give
you you know four thousand dollars three
thousand dollars
same in college in college it's gonna be
fit and match match one like a 401k you
know how does that match
yeah i'm gonna do it like that so do you
bring money home buddy no problem here
you go
you bring two thousand i'll match you
two thousand you bring a thousand i'm at
two thousand but you gotta bring yours
in as well positive reinforcement and
then eventually there's going to be a
certain level of money set aside in an
account
they have a choice on what they want to
do with it and if you want to use that
money to buy a house
great if you want to use that money to
run a business great if you want to use
that money to go to college great
you have a certain set of money that
you're dealing with but it's it's a
involved situation not a
i'm just you got to do your part as well
now here's what i'm thinking
and what i'm understanding here is
because you got no money like you said
no allowance i didn't get anything
planning for procreation yeah
i am um but you're using you're using
like clearly you're giving your kids
money 150 bucks a month
clearly you're willing to do something
for your kids but
with the with the with the understanding
that this is a lesson
this there's some learning going on here
you're going to learn how to save
you're going to learn how to budget
you're going to get money because you
did things the right way
you're not just going to be gifted money
you're on my silverstein are my kids
silver
spoon fed with me how are they with me
even though these guys have a father
that can probably buy them a lot of
things is it a pretty low standard
kickback no they have to read
they have to do their shots there's a
there's a
two ends of the spectrum here set up
standards on what they got exactly you
do that we're gonna have a good time
together we'll have a great relationship
together if you don't the bank is closed
it's that simple there is no bank i mean
you
you sat with the tv a broken tv for six
months because senator threw something
at the tv
intentionally yeah intentions
on a broken tv with a hole inside of it
i want you to watch this card
daddy i don't like that hole next time
don't break your tv yeah right
freaking so basically you're you're
willing to play you're willing to give
them discipline and self-control but i
love these guys man they're like my
world this morning i was late because i
went downstairs
and santa's like she goes she says daddy
homie
homie homie daddy she doesn't say hold
me she says homie
homie so i pick her up i'm calling so i
said how was your day in school
daddy school wasn't good why wasn't
school good
i don't like the swimming pool because i
don't like to swim in that pool why
don't you like to swim in that
chlorine hurts my eyes it hurts me i'm
like you freaking
you know she knows how to do it and
i'm talking to tico we're trying to
figure out where to put tico
like so tico what sport do you want to
take i want to take a comic book sport
class
what
[Laughter]
he says i want to take a coding class
where i can make movies i'm like
interesting so
do you want to take any like baseball
football basketball no but but you know
what i wouldn't mind taking a reading
class where we all sit together and read
i'm like
freaking love this science that's why
he's going to be a scientist and then
dylan's like yeah i want to take
track to beat everybody yeah awesome
girl playing football basketball soccer
it's so interesting by the way one of
the best experiences we've ever had
it was what our kids elementary school
public school was
we were assigned once a year a book to
read as a family
you sit down and read a book out loud
give a shout out to that school that's a
great school
armstrong elementary eagles private or
public public
get out of here this is texas yeah
fantastic like that's that's price
family reading so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye